when it comes to genres horror is one of
the hardest to get right the smallest
detail can break the spell filmmakers
rely on the suck viewers if and get them
invested in the scenes that will fuel
nightmares later it's all about timing
and balance so it's no surprise a lot of
otherwise good scenes can get the axe
sometimes those lost scenes are awesome
whether they give new insight into a
character or hint at a sequel they're
worth revisiting let's do exactly that
starting with a killer confrontation the
sauce series started out pretty basic
two guys leg chains hacksaws you know
the drill things would eventually get
more complicated but we could usually
count on Amanda staying relatively
strong up to her her violent end at
least as a victim turned willing
accomplice she needed to be a little
more complicated than most the other
characters who were of course usually
just tortured meat making the jump to
becoming jigsaw spawn is almost
unimaginable and this deleted scene from
saw three is a glimpse into that
struggle very rock star
sorry your hair it's very Rockstar it's
too bad we never got to see it because
it's particularly effective in the
series that could have benefited from
some relatable moments like this it's a
flashback to an atom who's oblivious to
what's in store for him and a chance
meeting that's about to go horribly
wrong we all know it even if they don't
I'll see you there
Henry's bad day it was one of the most
terrifying movies of 2017 penny wise
gave everyone another reason to fear
clowns that wasn't all for the losers
Club who also had classroom bully Henry
Bowers to deal with they know Henry's a
little unstable and we know it too one
blink and you miss a deleted scene would
have helped make the full extent of his
psychotic break completely clear
Henry sits in a car watching our
favorite group of losers head into the
most terrifying house we've ever seen
yes even including this one he has
company but friends belch and Victor
aren't feeling too talkative considering
what he's done to them and that just
really brings it home about just what
kind of bully the losers Club has had to
deal with on a daily basis that's the
very definition of horror - say what you
will about Pennywise but at least henry
makes your own school bully look
positively Pleasant evil Dead's extra
dark details the 2013 reboot of Evil
Dead was as ridiculously bloody as you'd
expect and director fede alvarez once
told collider I know we ordered a truck
of blood the other day that was 50,000
gallons just for one scene that's a
shocking amount of blood even though
most made an on screen for an insanely
blood-soaked finale there were still a
few details left on the cutting-room
floor in the original ending Mia's
brother Steve burns down the cabin it's
a sacrificial move as he traps himself
and their possess friend a deleted shot
shows a little more of what happens
inside the cabin as it's going up in
flames and spoiler alert it's not good
for Steve and in case you've ever
wondered just what happens when the
blood stopped flowing and the bodies are
done falling this cutscene shows just
how Mia got back to civilization
[Music]
are you okay kiddo neither shot adds
anything to the story but it's possible
that last glimpse of Steve might have
been setting off a sequel we hope
[Music]
[Applause]
a breathless confession 2016's don't
breathe might be one of the most tense
claustrophobic thrillers ever made and
it starts when three thieves decide to
break into the home of a blind man it's
not long before they realize they've
picked the wrong house
and it's Steven Lang's performance as
the intended victim that's at the heart
of the film since he doesn't have much
dialogue it's extra terrifying when he
does speak like he does in this deleted
scene my daughter
was my life and that might be why this
ended up on the cutting room floor it
might have given him just too much to
say going into some pretty explicit and
heartbreaking detail about the accident
that killed his daughter while it might
help us understand more about him the
explanation is ultimately unnecessary
the scene would have thrown a wrench
into the film's pacing but Lang's
reading of it is no less mesmerizing
than the rest of his performance extra
scares most elated scenes are short and
sweet but 2002's the ring lost an entire
subplot involving an accused murderer
played by Chris Cooper who shot scenes
to bookend the film while these scenes
unfortunately were never made available
to the public a few other deleted scenes
have slipped out one of the most
nerve-racking is an incredibly creepy
one in which Noah makes a horrifying
discovery as he heads off to investigate
the classic sort of creepy cabin
unfortunately for him a small boat
floating just offshore in the lake grabs
his attention
[Music]
okay it's effective but maybe too
effective the ultimately unnecessary
scene and subplot may have had the
effect of lessening similar scares at
earlier and later points in the film and
we can all agree the ring is pretty epic
without the added weight thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]